die ganze schlucht auf dem markt mit der
esa raumsonde mars express und der darin
verbauten high resolution stereo camera
konnte ein spektakuläres bild des mars
nordpols zusammengesetzt werden
was man auf dem bild sieht und welche
erkenntnisse wissenschaftlich darauf zu
erschließen hoffen jetzt bei 51 und weg
herzlich willkommen der mann aus der
rote planet ist für und menschen ja noch
immer ein großes fragezeichen in unserem
sonnensystem vor rund 3,5 milliarden
jahren soll es auf ihm ein feuchtwarmes
klima gegeben haben der mars rover
curiosity stief nahe des mount sharp auf
demente die sich in über zehn millionen
jahren in einem großen see abgelagert
hatten
das deutet darauf hin dass sie früher
auf dem mars ein thema gab dass weitere
langfristig bestehende sehen über den
mars verteilt entstehen ließ und damit
lebensfreundlich war verwehrten
zeitpunkt kann man mich gerade von
lebensfreundliche bedingungen sprechen
die luft auf dem mars ist extrem dünn
und das klima lässt auch zu wünschen
übrig die durchschnittstemperatur liegt
bei rund minus 50 grad fällt und so
wieder sein obwohl aus was er hier sind
die neuen bilder der rund 12 millionen
kubikkilometer riesigen aus wasser und
kohlendioxid ausgebildeten noch polkappe
des master ist mit sicherheit direkt der
im süden liegende riss aufgefallen die
sogenannte schachner boreale dort wollen
die forscher jetzt ansetzen um neues
über den mars zu erfahren in der
pressemitteilung des deutschen zentrums
für luft und raumfahrt heißes dazu zitat
schachner boreale die nördliche flucht
ist ein besonders auffälliger bis zu
zwei kilometer tiefer einschnitt bei
circa 300 grad ost mit einer länge von
500 kilometern und einer breite von bis
zu 100 kilometern an den steilen
abhängen windrichtung zu sehen die
ähnlich baumringen den jahre fertigen
wechsel von ablagerungen und staub
abdeckung durch die maus stürmer
widerspiegeln von der untersuchung
dieser schicht profile erhoffen sich die
wissenschaftler aufschlüsse über die
entwicklung des mars klima zitat ende
das ist wirklich eine sensationelle
entdeckung durch diese jahre
er kann tatsächlich die klimageschichte
das maß nachvollzogen werden
es ist immer spannend um den markt gehen
also mehr marty wirft ihr einfach auf
klicken und ihr könnt ihr auch mal aufs
auge drücken und fahren aber nicht an
die große glocke hängen nur draufklicken
gestampft bleibt dran also das nächste
video